good day and welcome everyone i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
please allow me to welcome you to
today's edition
of our 2020 2021 foundations of
biomedical data science seminar series
this lecture series is supported by
uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia
the uva brain institute the college of
arts and sciences
the school of data science and through a
grant from the national institutes of
general medical sciences
it is my honor and privilege today to
welcome our speaker
dr shefali jeste associate professor of
residence in psychiatry neurology
and pediatrics at the university of
california los angeles david geffen
school of medicine
dr jesse is a behavioral child
neurologist specializing in autism
and related neurodevelopmental disorders
when
she earned her bachelor's degree in
philosophy from yale university in 1997
and her md from harvard medical school
in 2002.
dr jesse then completed a residency in
child neurology and a fellowship in
behavioral child neurology
at the children's hospital of boston
she's conducted post-doctoral training
in developmental cognitive neuroscience
with the great charles nelson at harvard
medical school
where she gained expertise in the use of
high density electroencephalography
to characterize functional brain
development in infancy and early
childhood
particularly as it informs atypical
development
dr jesse's research is focused on
developing methods to improve precision
in the diagnosis and treatment of
developmental disorders from early
infancy through late childhood
among her many accomplishments she holds
several national and international
leadership positions
including the board of directors of the
american brain foundation
the board of directors of the national
organization for rare disorders
the board of directors for the
international society for autism
research
in 2019 she became the chair of the
international baby siblings research
consortium
and then also in 2019 she was awarded
the presidential early career award for
scientists and engineers
for her innovations in research in early
predictors
and intervention for genetic
neurodevelopmental disorders
today's presentation is entitled
clinical trial readiness for
neurodevelopmental disorders
on the road to precision health as
always we are streaming this lecture
live for recording via youtube if you
are watching on youtube thank you so
much for joining us today
also our specially selected 2020 2000
biomedical data science innovation lab
participants are encouraged to submit
any questions for dr jesse via the chat
feature of their zoom sessions
i'll synthesize all these questions and
ask them on your behalf during the last
10 minutes or so of the lecture
and with that welcome shefali we are so
excited to hear about your election
you're muted you would think after
a year of zoom i wouldn't do that so
thank you um jack and everyone for
inviting me um and for all those of you
who are joining on a i was gonna say
friday morning but you're on the east
coast so a little later for you
lunchtime break
um but yeah thanks so much for inviting
me and i'm really excited to speak with
you today um i love sharing our work
with folks with different backgrounds
and i think
you as many of your data scientists are
really critical for the kind of work
that we do
i'm going to keep this talk kind of high
level and really
give you a big picture with regards to
sort of where we are in
neurodevelopmental disabilities and our
efforts to really improve precision
health and clinical trial readiness
but i hope that as i do that um many of
you who are really
you know again using your expertise to
think about how we creatively can use
our big data systems
and our really complex data sets to help
answer some of the questions that we
need answered
hopefully that'll help you know motivate
you inspire you to kind of get involved
with this field if you
are not already and then i'm going to
make sure i keep some time for questions
at the end um because i'm not going into
the weeds with our methods
especially with the eeg methods but
happy to answer questions about that at
the end
um as we go so anyway thanks again for
inviting me and yeah so i'm a pediatric
neurologist
um these are my disclosures none of
which really have any um
bearing on what i'll talk about today um
but i'm a peds neurologist
as jack said i trained at boston
children's hospital and spent some time
working with chuck nelson
to really learn um about you know what
are the challenges and approaches that
we can take to understanding and
studying
early brain development because we know
that brain development is what has gone
in some ways sort of a skew in
neurodevelopmental disabilities and so i
learned some methods mostly eeg and then
moved to ucla in 2010 to be a part of
this large center that we call cart
center for autism research and treatment
and what's pretty cool about cart is
that it's a very integrated
multi-disciplinary team where we have
experts not just in sort of research and
early markers and genetics and
biomarkers but also experts in clinical
care
and treatment and a lot of the work that
we do is to integrate those disciplines
to really ask these important questions
about how do we improve diagnosis and
treatment
for neurodevelopmental disabilities um
and you'll hear a tiny bit about this
clinic that i started that is a
multidisciplinary program called
caring which stands for care and
research and neurogenetics
and it's a clinical platform where we
evaluate
and then help to manage kids and adults
who have genetic causes for their
neurodevelopmental disability
so what i'm going to do today is just go
through a few things so i'm going to
start by giving you this big overarching
view on how we think about precision
health in neurodevelopmental disorders
it's a big buzzword in the field of
medicine right now across the board
and it's become a reality
neurodevelopmental disabilities which is
super exciting
i'm then going to sort of shift a little
bit and talk about
you know sort of a reality check on this
excitement about precision health and
talk about you know what do we need to
do from the standpoint of clinical trial
readiness to make sure that
when the therapeutics are developed
we're ready with the trials and that's
really the bulk of my research is in
that space
and then finally just given the time
that we are in during covid
i am going to talk a bit about just
quickly five minutes about
considerations that we need to be making
both in clinical care and research
in neurodevelopmental disabilities
during this challenging time in kovid
which seems to
never be ending especially in los
angeles where our rates keep
rising um okay so just to get us all on
the same page since i know many of you
are not clinicians um what are
neurodevelopmental disorders so these
are diagnoses importantly that are based
on behaviors so they're based on a list
of symptoms that are in the chapter of
neurodevelopmental disorders in our
diagnostics and statistics manual the
newest version is dsm-5
what's important about these behaviors
is that they emerge early in development
and there's a lot of overlap in
symptomatology so the main diagnosis
you'll hear about with ndds are things
like
global developmental delay autism
spectrum disorder and intellectual
disability
there's others like adhd and social
communication disorder but it's really
global delay intellectual disability and
autism that you'll be that you'll hear
me talking about and
you'll hear me talking about work that's
really focused on autism but i just want
to emphasize that a lot of these
developmental disabilities overlap
what's important to know though is that
there's a tremendous amount of
heterogeneity in these different
diagnoses right so
you know you meet one there's a famous
quote that if you've met one child with
autism you've met one child with autism
um but the reality is that there is a
lot of variability in how kids get to
these list of symptoms if you will
um and part of the reason for that
heterogeneity is that there's a lot of
ideological heterogeneity now there's a
high genetic liability and we'll talk
about that
but there's many different biological
and even environmental ways that one can
arrive at these developmental
disabilities and so that really is
actually a challenge for us when we're
thinking about designing treatments
or even you know trying to identify
clinical patterns that we might want to
target again with treatments or with
evaluations
so despite all that heterogeneity though
our treatment model
has really historically been this so i
see a kiddo in clinic say with an autism
diagnosis right so autism you have
core um symptoms or deficits and social
behavior as well as the presence of
repetitive behaviors and restricted
interests or rbs
so i diagnose a child with autism and
then i
essentially recommend a treatment and
that treatment might be a behavioral
intervention or it might be a medication
and then basically what i'm looking for
is whether those basic core
symptoms have changed so i'm measuring
quite crudely often
that outcome which would be again those
core symptoms
um and again the treatment could be a
medication or a behavioral intervention
but you know it feels crude and as a
clinician
who's trying to be precise in diagnosis
it becomes a bit frustrating at times to
then say
you know i've made this really precise
diagnosis and now i'm just going to have
you go and
you know access whatever services your
regional center or your school system
can provide you
and we'll hope that we see a change in
your outcome
we'd like to move towards what we
consider precision health and i'm going
to sort of
operationalize precision health in a few
different ways for you guys but you know
the idea of precision health is that as
we start
understanding causes a bit better and we
identify specific clinical symptoms that
may be
more proximal to the cause we then can
identify treatments that actually might
be targeting those specific symptoms or
even the cause
and then our outcomes that we're
measuring might be a little more
specific again to that subgroup or to
that cause
and ideally would be evidence-based so
we actually have data on what those
outcomes might be that might be
measurable
um so this is kind of the basic rubric
really simplistic of where we'd like to
move from the standpoint of more
precision help
in neurodevelopmental disorders i love
this quote from
um obama timely this week to sort of
quote him
from his state of the union address you
know many years ago where he really put
forth a plan for a large federally
funded initiative towards precision
health that was um largely
sponsored by nih where he defined
precision health as delivering the right
treatment to the right patient every
time
and i think that's definitely a goal in
our case as well i'll add a few caveats
so at this point the one caveat will add
to that in neurodevelopmental
disabilities is that we also want to
make sure
that we provide the right treatment to
the right kid at the right time
and timing is often we think key in
these developmental disabilities where
we think that changes are occurring
even in utero right so we'd like to try
to target treatments as early as
possible
which is challenging for a variety of
reasons as we'll talk about
so how do we even start thinking about
precision health and neurodevelopmental
disorders like where do we look
given this big heterogeneous behavioral
set of conditions that we have
and this is where genetics has actually
been incredibly transformative and again
i'm going to summarize a bunch of stuff
in
sort of more simple slides just to make
the point but you know we've had a lot
of advances in how we examine
clinically examine you know genetic
etiologies of disease and
and conditions um you know we just use
the basic karyotype to look at changes
in the number of chromosomes
that's moved now to using microarray
technology to identify
duplications or deletions in the
chromosomes that are you know up to 50
or 100 kilobases in size
and then of course now even more
clinically common is is actually whole
exome or whole genome sequencing
where we can identify changes at this at
the level of the single base pair
which helps us to identify single gene
disorders
um and with that technology what's
happened is that and this is just a
rubric
is that we've actually identified um you
know
not just these big single gene disorders
like tuberous sclerosis that we've known
about for a long time that cause
neurodevelopmental disabilities
but also copy number variance syndromes
like 15q duplication syndrome that
you'll hear me talk about a bit later
as well as these very small single gene
mutations
and now taken together you know these
don't account for all of autism
or all of neurodevelopmental
disabilities but the number
is increasing in terms of the number of
um kids or even adults that we
identified that have these putative
causes
and what's important actually and
interesting now is that with all that
all the research done in in sort of
autism and neurodevelopmental genetics
it's now actually translated to clinical
care and now genetic testing is
really the only routinely recommended
medical workup for an individual with
autism or
you know intellectual disability um and
the clinical gold standard is that we do
a microarray
and then some other testing based on the
sex of the child
um whole exome sequencing is often
performed if the microarray is negative
because remember the microarray
identifies copy number variants it will
miss single gene
um mutations and other kinds of very
small
variants and so exome is performed
there's been a bunch of meta-analyses
that i'm not going to show here that
have looked at the clinical utility of
whole exome sequencing
and it's found in certain cases where
there's a high pretest probability
uh that the the um the yield can be as
high as 50
so we're really moving into this place
and the next set of recommendations
probably will include whole exome
sequencing
so why is that important well first of
all we've identified now that about 25
of individuals with a neurodevelopmental
disability have an identified genetic
cause
so we're starting to think about you
know can we learn something from these
syndromic neurodevelopmental disorders
because we know cause at this point
right and then again if we think about
precision health
we've opened a big door um so before i
sort of get
into that um i want to just make a
couple of important clinical
uh points that i think are really
relevant when we think about these kids
with identified genetic causes
so one is that clinically these kids do
tend to be more affected and i want to
be really clear about that sometimes you
know people talk about
you know certain genetic conditions as
being models for autism or models
for neurodevelopmental disease and i
always am very clear to say like you
know these kids with
some of these really large de novo
mutations or variants
they're very clinically affected so they
don't represent the whole spectrum right
they often represent the end of the
spectrum that are more
maybe clinically challenged in different
ways and what does that mean
so these kids often don't just have an
autism diagnosis and i don't mean to say
just to belittle the importance of that
diagnosis rather that
they don't they don't simply have the
social communication
challenges or repetitive behaviors they
also have global developmental delay
especially motor delays and hypotonia
often have comorbid intellectual
disability and importantly often have
other comorbidities not just medical
ones but neurological ones like epilepsy
so in certain conditions we're seeing
epilepsy in up to 50 or
75 percent of children and epilepsy is
just having more than one
um unexplained or un um unprovoked
seizure
uh so you know these are kids who are a
little bit more medically and clinically
complex
but you could argue these are also kids
where we're really desperate for
treatments right to really mitigate some
of these issues that occur over a
lifetime
the other really important point though
and again has been a really huge source
of
advancement actually over the last many
years is that as these
individual rare conditions are
identified right so again individually
if you noticed on the slide a couple of
slides ago that i showed you
individually rare meaning each one
accounts for maybe at the most one
percent of the whole spectrum
together again they they account for
about 25
but each of these rare conditions what
happens is with social media and
all of these other platforms these
parents converge right they communicate
and they start talking about how they
can work together
to really accelerate not just a clinical
understanding of these
various conditions but also really
accelerate research
and so all these different parent groups
are called pads patient advocacy groups
and what they have done over the last
i'd say decade is really
um improve our efforts in not just
supporting families and advocating
but in facilitating clinical care
through developing
centers of excellence around the country
for specific conditions
as well as facilitating research and
this is where again some of you's
data scientists might be interested but
you know one of the big challenges
um for these families is like how do we
collect common data points across
all these different you know families
that are all over the world and how do
we put them into one registry it seems
like a simple problem
but i cannot tell you how many groups
struggle with this
and now there's efforts through this
actually group that you can see here
agenda which is a collaboration of all
of these different pages
with which i'm involved and it's
sponsored by the autism science
foundation the goal is to try to have
these packs talk to each other to try to
develop some common tools
but they're really working on developing
registries developing bio repositories
and then ideally developing platforms
for trials and again i'm going to show
you some examples of that but
these tags have been really critical in
moving this research forward
but the big data issue or not even big
data just the data harmonization issues
one that they're all still
often struggling with okay so back to
the precision health right so what can
we do in neurodevelopmental disabilities
when we think about these genetic
conditions
well we can start thinking about
syndrome-specific
treatments so as opposed to a standard
approach where you take the whole sample
of neurodevelopmental disorders you
choose a you know a random cohort and
you identify
you know a drug that might be effective
instead we take a tailored approach
and we identify these subgroups that are
again genetically identified at this
point
and then think about treatments that
would be effective based on the
understanding of the mechanism of action
of the
uh of the genetic change and that's
exactly what's happened in our field and
again in the interest of time i'm not
going
to go through the different methods i'm
happy to answer questions
but you know there's medications that
are more targeted to certain pathways
there's gene editing
methodologies like crispr cas9 that's
been very exciting
and then most you know most relevant
right now are actually these antisense
oligonucleotides
and so what is an aso it's basically
just a small sequence right of rna that
can bind
to the transcribed rna and change
basically protein translation
and so that that technology has really
been leveraged in the last few years
to be able to affect the downstream
effects of some of these genetic
variants and i'll give you one example
which is not even
really a neurodevelopmental disorder but
it completely blew the doors open in
child neurology i'll say which is
um the aso therapy for spinal muscular
atrophy so this is
a devastating condition that affects um
you know the most if the most severe
kind affects kids in early infancy
um where they don't have production of a
really important um
protein called smn and that protein is
very important for just the functioning
of our motor neurons
and so when children have sma they don't
have basically
strength they don't have any motor
function and so you can imagine that
affects their respirations as well as
their
movements and many of these children
actually die in the first year of life
and so an aso therapy was developed to
be able to essentially
unsilence the silenced smn protein that
is again typically silenced in our
bodies
because again they have a deletion of
one of the smn protein um genes
and with that aso um this
this trial that was started again many
years ago halfway through the trial they
found that it was so effective that they
stopped the trial and made this
an fda approved drug called spin raza
and now we've
infants who are receiving this drug who
are living a full life
i mean completely curative right so it
just shows that these
conditions that we thought were never
going to be able to be treated
are now able to be treated and i want to
be clear i'm not trying to compare
a neurodevelopmental disability to
spinal muscular atrophy i'm just giving
the point that
you know with an understanding of
underlying mechanisms we
can actually develop treatments that
could be
deemed as transformative or if you want
to use the word curative
in this case i think we would use that
for sma
and what's happened now in the
neurodevelopmental disability space is
that these aso
and drug trials have been now launched
in various conditions and i'll just
point out a couple
so tangelo is a rose trial and it's an
aso for angelman syndrome
i won't get into all the details but
angelman is caused by a deletion of ub3a
which is a gene that's maternally
imprinted so in our in our healthy
brains we have a paternal ub3 that's
silenced and a maternal ub3 that's
active
and an angelman the maternal ub theory a
is deleted
so what this aso does is it unsilences
the paternal uv-3a
um and we actually just had our first
ucla tengelo patient get dosed this week
so incredibly exciting again the data
are obviously not out yet but
the goal is that we can at least slow
down progression
or or even possibly reverse some of the
neurodevelopmental manifestations of
these genetic conditions
so this is the era we're in right now
you know super exciting and i really am
careful as a clinician not to oversell
these opportunities because we don't
know yet right but
if you think about where we've come from
where we were 10 years ago when we were
making genetic diagnoses that
sometimes felt academic right they let
us they helped us inform parents about
why
their child might have developmental
delay or not have language or have
epilepsy or have autism
now we're at a point where we can say
hey based on a cause and based on our
understanding with pre-clinical models
and everything else
the underlying sort of downstream
effects of that genetic variant or
change
based on that we actually might have a
therapeutic that could really
fundamentally change the way the brain
our brain
developmental trajectories are going to
progress and that's a very different
conversation that i have with parents
now in some cases right than i did many
years ago and so it's really exciting
so as i get you all excited i also have
to then also be
you know the tale of caution which is
that as these therapies are
created we have to be ready and what
does that mean we have to be able to
have the data
necessary to develop
and design and implement clinical trials
that will truly tell us if the drug
works
and unfortunately in neurodevelopmental
disabilities we've been stymied by
clinical trials being deemed as failures
you know and there's a lot of reasons
for that and we'll talk about it but you
know we've had trials where people have
been excited about you know drugs maybe
more
char you know for the broader autism
spectrum rather than for specific
genetic etiologies but a lot of
excitement around
trials that then in the end you know the
drug doesn't seem to be more effective
than
a comparison group and then it's you
know never approved for use
and that really leads to some
discouragement but i would argue that
it's probably not always the case that
it's because the drug doesn't work it
might also be because
we don't have the right trial design so
let's talk about that for a minute right
so just
again this is really basic 101 and many
of you probably already know this but
it helps when we think about again how
we can um
you know improve clinical trial
readiness which is again going to be the
bulk of the
rest of this talk so when we how do our
trials design so typically in a trial
you know you take your
initial population of interest and again
there can be quite a bit of
um stratification that's done up front
but you take your population of interest
and
randomly split them into two groups
right and then one group receives an
intervention
and the other groups receive receives a
placebo and i won't get into it there's
lots of different trial designs that um
uh
allow for us not to have to do a pure
placebo like you know sugar pill or
whatever so that people do
always have a chance to get treatment
they're staggered
weightless designs and things like that
but fundamentally the idea with the
trial is that you're asking whether the
intervention group
uh has made gains in whatever your
outcome measures of interest are
have they made gains above and beyond
what we would see in patients who did
not receive the treatment
that's the bottom line so why are we
challenged in
um in neurodevelopmental disability
clinical trials especially in these
syndromes
so what the first is that we don't have
great measures of drug target engagement
meaning we don't know if the drug
actually hit the target
before we decide to then launch into a
one-year trial to follow outcome
right so it'd be really helpful to have
some measures of that
the second and this is a big one is that
our standardized clinical measures that
we use to assess
development cognition social skills they
often don't adequately capture
function or even change especially in
these populations that are more severely
affected
and i'll show you an example of that and
then lastly
as you can imagine i mean these
syndromes are rare individually right
these kids are
all over the country in the world so how
do we actually
get a sample size big enough right to be
able to answer the questions that we
need to answer when you can't just
recruit locally
right these kids are everywhere so those
are i would say the three really big
areas of challenge and so we in our
group have actually
been doing research to try to address
all of these areas and what i'm going to
do in the next like
you know uh like 15 minutes or so is
kind of show you
examples of what we've done in these
three areas and again
each of them could be their own talk in
the interest of time and also just to
give you kind of a high level view i'm
just going to show you
examples but happy to answer more
questions about them and a lot of the
stuff is
published or recently published as well
so um okay so the first is
this issue of drug target engagement
right how do we address that and so the
way that we've sort of
tackled this and again this is not just
my group this is the groups around the
country and world
is that we can start thinking about how
do we identify mechanistic biomarkers
right that really inform drug target
engagement so biomarkers that we
think reflect the putative target of the
drug
and that we also think reflect maybe
some of the
mechanism underlying disease or
disability in these in these um patients
um with regards to this issue around
this the challenge around standardized
clinical measures
um we've been doing quite a bit of work
thinking about and developing through
big cohort studies um you know through
an evidence-based approach what are the
most meaningful and measurable clinical
endpoints so we need to test those
clinical measures
in these populations directly to then be
able to answer the question about test
retest reliability or stratification and
those sorts of things
and then lastly from the standpoint of
the challenge around the rarity of these
conditions
you know we've been working to design
protocols and develop methods that
really maximize access and scalability
and this has become amplified during
covid
because forget about whether someone has
a rare condition or not these
approaches that we take to figure out
improved access are going to be relevant
across the board because right now
families can't travel even if they are
local
because of restrictions and so we've had
to be really creative with that and i'll
show you a bit about that at the end
okay so let's start with this issue
about biomarkers so what is a biomarker
right so biomarker is just
any characteristic that's objectively
measured and evaluated that indicates
either a normal biological process
a pathogenic process or a response to
treatment
there's a lot of interest and excitement
about biomarkers and autism right now
and i'll just mention that there's a
large nih-funded
autism biomarkers consortium for
clinical trials of which we are a part
jamie mcpartland at yale is the pi and
our goal is to use methods like eeg and
eye tracking
to quantify some biomarkers that will
help us stratify kids with autism
and might be sensitive to change over
time so this this consortium study is
not a trial itself
it's really a big data gathering
initiative and some of those papers have
are getting published right now from our
first wave we just got refunded to start
again this summer
um but you know you might ask well what
kind of methods and what kind of
biomarkers do we use for a
neurodevelopmental disorder well
um this is again where genetics can help
us think about it and this is kind of a
busy figure so if you have a small
screen you might not see it well
this is a great review by luis de la
torre from nature medicine a few years
ago
where he basically looked at kind of
what were the what are the
convergent mechanisms and pathways that
underlie these like hundreds of putative
genes that cause autism and
neurodevelopmental disabilities
and it turns out not surprisingly that
the many many genes that are affected
um and that are causative really do
impact these basic neurodevelopmental
processes like
protein translation and synaptic
signaling and that these
effects and the initial effects of these
genetic changes occur before birth so
this circle is
you know is um birth right so these are
coming online
in in uto in utero fetal brain
development
um and fundamentally again as i
mentioned they're affecting things like
synaptic signaling
gliogenesis migration differentiation
and when you look even sort of at a
slightly sort of macro scale as to what
these different pathways
um actually do affect at the level of
brain function
they fundamentally affect brain circuit
function right so they're affecting the
way
as i like to think about it the way the
brain is wired right so it's not that
these
um that were we're seeing a break or a
um you know or a you know uh yeah a
break
in healthy connections that have already
been formed
it's that these sort of network level um
you know changes that are supposed to
occur and typical development are just
not forming in the same way
and that actually led to this coining of
the term by dan geshwind and pat levitt
many years ago that
autism and neurodevelopmental disorders
were developmental disconnections
so again it's these these connections
are just not forming in the way they
might form in typical development
so how do we test that right and so
again a bit of an oversimplified slide
and if
any of your electrophysiologists you
might appreciate this but
you know we've been using eeg as a
really beautiful
temporally sensitive tool to really
assay neural circuit function in real
time
right so we can really probe that
circuit with scalp level
um detection again this is a picture of
the kind of nets that we use but there's
lots of different ways that we can
collect these data
and you know fundamentally what is eeg
it's really measuring at the scalp
the synchronous firing of neurons in
real time right so it's a
it's a fairly nice you know somewhat
indirect although i would argue
not so indirect measure of healthy
circuit function and development
and there's so much that we can do with
the signal and i we my lab has published
a lot of eg papers i'm not going to go
into all the methods but just to say
that
that kind of crude signal we get at the
scalp we can break down into component
parts
and calculate you know the oscillatory
power in different frequency bands
we can look at peak frequency and we've
done a lot of work looking at peak alpha
frequency in particular
as a very sensitive measure of really
healthy brain development
and we also can infer connectivity so
unlike with imaging where we can really
look nicely at structural connectivity
with eg we cannot do that but we can do
is using tools like um
and signal processing methodologies like
coherence
we can ask how in sync is the signal in
different parts of the brain
and by doing so we can infer how
connected
different um parts of brain regions are
okay so that and we
we have focused quite a bit on um alpha
phase coherence in our lab
and so using eeg as a method um we can
really start to ask these questions
about you know
are there robust biomarkers in these
neurodevelopmental disorders and i'll
give you
um one example of the infancy work again
and this is again a talk unto itself i
didn't want to focus on that today
because i'm trying to tell the story
around clinical trials but we've
actually for a long time been studying
infants who are considered at higher
likelihood or higher risk for having a
neurodevelopmental disability
either because they have a genetic
syndrome or because they have an older
sibling
with autism um you know the baby
siblings group is one that's been
studied for a decade and jack mentioned
at the beginning that we have a large
international consortium actually of
researchers who have been studying baby
siblings
um and i've been sharing that consortium
just for the last year but um you know
there's
been quite a bit of work in that
consortium using
methods like eeg to study early brain
development
and so this was a study that just got
published and abby dickinson who's a
really phenomenal research scientist in
the lab worked with actually a bunch of
data scientists
on this and took kind of a um uh
i'd like to think of it as like a clear
box machine learning approach where they
basically asked you know which
networks which set of networks which we
called features um
and the networks were defined again by
phase coherence between two
electrodes essentially which networks
most robustly um relate to and predict
later [ __ ] scores and [ __ ] is a clinical
measure of autism
but the nice thing about the way that
they did this algorithm is they were
able to then go back and
look to see what the networks were so
they could be interpreted and what we
basically found was this pattern
of hypoconnectivity or reduced face
coherence in frontal cortical
regions and a pattern of increased
connectivity increased base coherence
in temporal parietal regions which is
interesting because those are networks
that have been
for a long time in the imaging work been
implicated in autism right frontal
cortical regions being really critical
for attentional networks especially
social attention whereas these temporal
parietal networks have been more
clearly linked to really social
cognition and social motivation
so um again really interesting work just
got published and i'm happy to share
that paper with you guys but
our next step is really to replicate
this right in a larger sample but this
shows that and sorry i didn't mention
this is in three month olds
so you know this shows that we can use
eg to kind of map these changes
very early in development how robust
they are how predictive they are
definitely still needs work so i don't
oversell the finding but i just want to
show that we can use eg in these ways
okay so back to sort of thinking about
these syndromes and how eeg might be a
useful biomarker
we've been studying a bunch of these
different really highly penetrant you
know for neurodevelopmental disabilities
genetic syndromes
and one in particular we've been really
interested in and i think it just is a
good example of the kinds of ways we can
use
biomarkers to study these conditions is
do 15 q syndrome
so do 15 q is a syndrome caused by a
duplication on chromosome 15 q
um you can see here the um the the
region that's duplicated and there's a
bunch of really important genes for
brain development in this region
including the maternally imprinted ub3a
which i mentioned earlier that's deleted
in angelman syndrome
in do 15q it's overexpressed and there's
also
a cluster of gaba receptor genes and
that's important because we do really
believe that gaba neurotransmission is
profoundly altered
in these in these individuals and what
we know about do 15 q syndrome is that
it's highly penetrant for
neurodevelopmental disabilities so these
kids have hypotonia global delay autism
as well as epilepsy what got us actually
quite interested in this condition
is that there was a case series that was
published many years ago
where they were describing the clinical
eegs of these children and you know
these kids get clinical eg's undergo
clinical eegs because they have epilepsy
so they need to get eegs from monitoring
and what was found was that these kids
had this sort of high frequency
oscillations on their clinical eg
now as a neurologist when i see this eeg
pattern it makes me think about um
it makes me think the child's taking a
gaba positive allosteric modulator like
ativan or valium um so when you actually
caught you know increase gaba signaling
in with pharmacologically you actually
get these high frequency beta
oscillations
these kids are not taking these
medications so when we saw this we
thought oh my goodness this might be a
biomarker
of underlying of that gaba those gaba
genes being over expressed in ultra gaba
neurotransmission
so let's try to really quantify and
study this biomarker
and that's just what we did and again
this has been published over the last
few years this is great work done by a
couple of
amazing graduate students and a
statistician named domina
center um but what we found using our
signal processing methods is that
um in do 15q this is just sort of like a
heat map a topo plot
just in the beta band range which is
like 15 to 30 hertz we see
much higher beta activity in duke 15q
compared to iq matched kids with
non-syndromic autism
and typically developing kids this is a
power spectral density plot also just
showing this big gaba peak and this is
was huge the effect size is almost
two here scatter plot showing the same
thing with the high beta and the kids
would do 15 q
since then we've done quite a bit of
work that was recently published asking
about whether it's stable over time that
biomarker the answer is
yes whether it's scalable can we measure
and quantify this not just in our
research eg but also in our clinical eeg
answer is yes um and it's also led to
this very interesting path that i'm not
going to get into today but if you're
interested
once it's published i'll send you the
paper we just submitted it where we
started looking at um eeg and sleep
because i was wondering if
sleep physiology was altered given that
we see these high beta oscillations in
the awake stage and i thought if sleep
physiology is altered
that might have a profound implication
on cognitive development
and so we went down this pathway um and
found
actually that there is profoundly
altered sleep physiology in these kids
not just in the fact that they beta at
night but in their slow wave
oscillations and their spindles
and we think that's going to be a really
important actually target for
therapeutics
so that's an example of a really nice
biomarker right and so taking it back to
this rubric
of precision health let's just sort of
operationalize this before we talk about
the clinical endpoints which is kind of
the next
area um which is you know imagine that
we see a child with
dupe 15 q syndrome right here or has
symptoms right global delay autism
some seizures and we get the molecular
diagnosis of duke 15q
well imagine now that we actually
conduct our eeg assessment we find this
beta biomarker
uh and then we have the opportunity and
this is literally in the works right now
that there
are drugs that are gaba negative
allosteric modulators that actually can
reduce that over the over expression and
the over
the excessive gaba signaling well then
that
those beta oscillations might be a
really robust marker of drug target
engagement to know that that
gabaergic treatment if you will that
modulator did hit the target
that's exactly the what we're in the
midst of designing right now with some
um
with some trials so very exciting and
it's really accelerated again and
changed the way we're thinking about
how these biomarkers can be used in
trials
okay so the next part that you know i
mentioned was just that so now we have
these biomarkers now what about
meaningful endpoints how do we even
think about that i'm not going to spend
a ton of time on this
um especially because i know a bunch of
you aren't like clinicians clinicians i
won't go into
the weeds on this but i do want to show
you this because i do again think as
data scientists this is relevant because
we really struggle with sample sizes and
thinking about how to harmonize data in
these ways so we
um you know with the same syndrome do 15
q syndrome
you know we wanted to really understand
what is the clinical phenotype and how
do
our measures of cognition motor skills
and adaptive skills how do they behave
in this population because we're getting
ready to design a trial we want to know
what our endpoints should be
and so going back to the slide i just
showed you what we did was we didn't
just collect data at ucla we actually
took our team on the road
and we went to multiple family meetings
where we could collect
phenotyping data we actually did eeg
assessments there as well for some of
the papers that i mentioned
earlier because it was the most
effective way to get access to these
families
and they were very responsive to that so
what did we find okay so
the one of the first things we found
when we actually did our battery of
assessments
and we also compared these kids to
non-syndromic autism is we found that
these kids have
really significant motor impairment
compared to non-syndromic autism
this is on the vineland and this is on
the mullen if you're familiar with those
measures so this is a parent report this
is direct assessment
so big picture significant motor delays
and motor impairments above and beyond
what we see in non-syndromic autism
this actually is it has been
corroborated in large cohort studies
like in the simon simplex collection
which some of you might know about
where um they also did a study where
they looked at various measures
in kids who had causative genetic
syndromic basically autism compared to
non-syndromic
and the biggest differentiator was age
of walking so later age of walking and
kids who had
causative genetic variants so we
asked well you know our motor measures
are really crude can we
develop more quantitative ways to assess
motor skills and i don't take credit for
this work this is a fantastic
junior faculty member in my lab who was
a postdoc with me and now she's a k
um 23 to really explore this she used
gate mat technology to better quantify
deficits and gait
in kids would do 15q this is actually a
kiddo with duke15q
at one of the family meetings they took
this huge gate mat and
schlepped it to a family meeting to
collect data and you can see that kids
would do 15q
have different gaits than kids with
non-syndromic autism
and specifically what what this dr
wilson found was that
these kids have slower velocity of gait
as well as um shorter step lengths um
and this is a nice measure right this is
something that's quantitative you could
argue it's almost more like a bio in the
biomarker category than clinical
assessment
but think that this is something that we
can use to measure
if we think that some of these drugs
will actually improve motor skills
probably in a way
a little less crude than some of our
standardized measures
we also though did and i won't spend a
lot of time on this we did
collect again a lot of standardized data
and you'll see where the challenges are
and again for you guys as data
scientists i want to show you this so
you can think about how do you how do we
think about solving some of these
problems
so this is just um a cognitive
assessment called the mullen and we just
did
age we call them ratio iqs so it's
really the age equivalence over the
chronological age
and even using that kind of ratio iq
score
you can see and again a hundred is
considered quote normal
right look how low these kids are most
of these many of these kids are at the
floor
particularly kids with seizures so kids
with seizures are more effective than
kids without that's sort of a known
phenomenon in clinical medicine
but you know we have kids who are really
falling on the floor so how do we
use those measures when we want to maybe
target cognition
as an end point for a trial right um
interestingly though when we actually
look at other measures of functioning
like the vineland which is a parent
report measure of adaptive skills
we see a bit better stratification and
kids aren't quite at the floor as much
right now that may be partly a bias of
parent reporting or it might be that
that measure is actually just collecting
data that is a little more sensitive
to subtle abilities that these kids have
but we like these kinds of measures that
have a histogram like this versus one
that has a big left shift
but we have to contend with this because
these are the measures that we have to
work with right
um and so you know we based on that work
and this paper just got published
actually you know we've been really
thinking about how can we be more
flexible
and ident in studying and testing
cognitive abilities
in these kids um you know there's other
questionnaires we can use to look at
comorbidities and social skills like the
srs and the cbcl
and i'll tell you that we struggled with
those measures for these kids with more
significant disabilities
because some of the questions that are
asked of parents are just not answerable
so for instance you know on the srs and
it's a great measure
the srs has a lot of strengths and value
to to it
but you know some of the questions are
things like you know your child's aware
of what others are thinking
or gives unusual reasons for doing
things well if a child's nonverbal
um you know that's going to be a
difficult question for a parent to
answer so then we get a lot of missing
data so we have questionnaires we're
missing a third of the answers because
parents don't know how to answer it
how do we deal with that how do we use
that as a measure of outcome
right so those are sort of issues we're
still grappling with and ones that
hopefully some of you can help
to address but taking us back to now
this rubric of precision health again
you know we talked about the biomarker
in do 15q well now based on some of the
studies we've been doing with our larger
cohorts
we can start being a little bit more
precise with thinking about outcome
so you might not use a ratio iq score or
a full iq
we might use quantitative motor skills
we're definitely going to be excited
about asking about adaptive skills
and maybe we'll use raw scores for our
developmental or cognitive assessments
because
even one behavior or ability that's
gained
might be meaningful right so but we're
gonna really change the way we're
thinking about outcomes based on the
kind of data that we're collecting
and this work is ongoing and there's a
lot of sites around the country that are
sort of
collaborating on thinking about these
challenges
okay good i'm doing well with time so
the last couple of pieces i'm gonna
try to be done in about seven or eight
minutes and then i'll have time for
questions
um so lastly is this issue about that
the fact that these syndromes are rare
i'm not going to spend a lot of time on
this one i just want to emphasize that
we
are working hard as a field to develop
protocols that are more accessible
and i'll give you one example so this is
we've been studying another rare
condition called tuberosclerosis
details don't matter actually for the
purposes of what i want to talk about
what i will what i will emphasize is
that tsc is often diagnosed in utero
um these kids have these benign
hamartomas or tumors in the brain this
is a
fetal mri as well as in the heart that's
the fetal ultrasound
that are picked up early and and what we
also know is that more than half of
these children end up being diagnosed
with autism
so we've been over the last 10 years
studying these infants prospectively
from early infancy to ask
are there early predictors that we can
then target right can we start getting
these kids into early intervention early
on
and what we found in all this work has
been published this is in the blue box
we have found that by 12 months of age
we can identify pretty robustly delays
in
non-verbal cognition social
communication skills and actually with
eeg we've identified biomarkers of
atypical development
both in peak alpha and in phase
coherence that relate to later
neurodevelopmental outcomes
so we have these robust measures right
and so what's the obvious next step well
we need a treatment
and so we designed and were funded a
couple of years ago through nih
to run the first randomized control
trial of behavioral intervention
for infants with tuberous sclerosis and
this was a intervention called jasper
that was developed by connie castry ucla
it's a really beautiful intervention
that really targets some of the core
symptoms that we were identifying in tsc
so
it targets joint attention and social
communication skills
and so our question was basically do
infants who receive weekly jasper
do they show better neurodevelopmental
outcomes than those that do not
and we have like a weightless control
design so everyone eventually gets
jasper
but some kids have to wait three months
because we felt like ethically we wanted
to make sure everyone had a chance to
get the treatment
because they never had access to this
before and the way the study was
originally designed was that they were
coming in
every week to either ucla or boston
children's hospital
for the intervention there was a lot of
excitement around the study when it was
when it was launched and you know social
media and
the press and the patient advocacy group
everyone was getting excited about this
and in our first year of funding this is
an r01 so this is not trivial amount of
funding this was our enrollment table
so yellow were the number of families
enrolled so you can do the math and
realize that is not enough families our
goal was 60.
but the purple dots were people who were
interested but didn't enroll so you can
imagine
why right or maybe you can't but what
what might be an issue right look at
that map right these kids are all over
the place
and essentially parents said we just
can't do it it's not convenient
basically and one parent actually said
if virtual ever becomes an option we'd
be interested
so we went back to the drawing board and
we basically
converted the entire jasper study which
is called jets jasper early intervention
for ts
to a remote delivery um parents still
have to come in once at baseline for the
eeg and the assessment but after that
what we do is we give the parents an
ipad
um and the they get trained once in
person this is just a picture in the
interest of time i won't show the videos
but the um examiner base or the
interventionist teaches the parent in
real time
um about the intervention and then the
parent goes home and practices
and every week they upload their video
on their ipad to box
it's very archaic but it works the
interventionist then
downloads it from box reviews it and
then they do a zoom call once a week and
this was pre-coded that we started this
every week there's a new module the
parent gets trained again
remotely they practice same cycle uh
and so the whole thing is parent
mediated done remotely so
we made that change and within six
months this was our enrollment
map and we've continued to enroll we're
not done with the trial yet
but it's been super exciting and i think
that that and we just published actually
that paper
to describe the methods and you know
there's there's lots of studies now this
is an angel in natural history study
that's all remote
right or mostly remote with in-home
assessments because we all recognize
that it's hard for families to come
especially when they're geographically
dispersed and have kids with complex
medical issues
so that's a great example and we're
doing a lot more work in that area now
okay so i'm gonna end with like two
minutes on this because i just think
it's an important thing for us to all
sort of be on the same page about which
is
how have we had to modify things and how
we had to think about these families
in the era of covid and i'll highlight a
really nice letter to the editor that
john constantino wrote with joe piven
and some others
recently about you know just the impact
of covet restrictions on individuals
with idds
um and you know what they said this
quote i thought was really
powerful and i see it every day when i
see patients in clinic
which is that among non-infected persons
in the u.s there's there's few more
adversely affected than individuals with
idds and why is that guys well you know
these individuals they rely on intensive
services especially in home services
right that they're not able to get now
they need more close medical monitoring
which is also hard to implement remotely
they're also more overall vulnerable to
the impact of the educational
mitigation efforts right not being in
school during the day zoom is very
hard for a child who has significant
intellectual disability or has autism or
limited attention
um and so this is really important and
so we actually did a survey to really
understand the effects of
covid on individuals with idds ndds
and the first survey was done in april
and that was already published and we're
doing a second wave actually now
but just some highlights and again that
paper just came out so i can share it
with you or you can find it on pubmed
but you know important facts like more
than half were unable to see at least
one health care provider
you know third three quarters lost
access to at least one educational
services
um and we had a handful that thirty
percent had lost access to all their
services
um but you know interestingly when we
asked parents what would you like to see
you know preserved access to clinical
trials is one of their biggest
priorities like they want to still be in
trials they want to still be involved
with research
and so we have to think about how to
keep moving forward
even though we have these challenges and
and these um
restrictions um and so we've made a big
shift in a lot of our research and
clinical care a lot of the stuff that i
described that we're doing
we're you know the biomarkers work the
clinical endpoint work we're still doing
it we're just having to be more creative
right so we're incorporating telehealth
quite a bit more
we're working on validating remote
behavioral assessments and this is a big
consortium-wide effort with the bsrc
and some others we're figuring out ways
to collect biomarker data remotely
through signal processing of clinical
eegs even portable systems
um and you know we're just thinking
about how do we do all this while
preventing this
widening of disparities that that
inherently occur
for parents who don't have access to
technology the same way that some of our
moral resource parents do um we have
been bringing kids back to the lab for
eeg though and i'll show you some of the
things we've done we moved our entire
control
system outside of into the hallway this
is one of this is my
one the hallway of my lab all these
doors are eeg testing rooms actually
this is one of our rooms the parents on
the inside with the kid they become the
behavioral assistant so we have no one
in the room with the child
so the parent does everything we coach
them ahead of time send them a video and
all kinds of documents to help them get
ready to prevent their child from
pulling at the net and those sorts
of things um uh oops sorry i hope you
can still see my screen um
but our control you know system is
outside we have a plexiglas
wall here so if there is an examiner on
the side they're at least separated a
bit from the family
because the kids are not wearing masks
usually just the parent is
but we're doing a lot of these different
changes and i can talk to you more about
that
um now that i'm done so i'll just end
with this right so we talked about
precision health right delivering the
right treatment to the right patient
every time
at the right time and you know i just
say that right now in covid we also have
to think about how do we do all that
safely and accessibly
and that's been sort of something we've
spent quite a bit of time contemplating
and
you know persevering through over this
last few months
um and with that i'll stop and just say
thank you um for listening
we have a bunch of funders that we
appreciate greatly this is my amazing
lab
um pre-covered um you know now we're
doing a lot of things on zoom this is
actually a group of students who are
working with me this summer and
we had to coach and mentor students
completely remotely this year so that
was i'm sure you're going through the
same thing
and it's definitely a learning curve so
with that i will stop
and i'm happy to take questions
okay should i stop share are you guys
hi sorry about that i just needed to
unmute myself
and couldn't find the button thank you
so much for
this is a fantastic and wonderful talk
this is just
uh very very well done it is a tour de
force amount of work and so
congratulations to you and your team for
for all of it i want to start off by
asking you a quick question
yeah which you kind of covered you
covered biomarkers and eeg and genetic
testing and cognitive assessments etc
he talked about some of the treatments
that can can go on
um and and some of the effects of those
treatments and their their
effects on cognitive and motor results
and then
clinical endpoints and hopefully cures
for some of these
sort of disorders one of the questions i
wanted to
start with is can you discuss some of
the ethical
issues involved in the start points you
know we want to get to end points
obviously
but where do you start and you kind of
mentioned children being
genetically tested in utero um you
mentioned
you know some other things about you
know when these things would start in
childhood to hopefully
kind of head these things off the past
what are some of the
ethical issues about this that you've
encountered and that you know people
discuss
in the field that people might be
interested in knowing about
great great question jack and i think um
there's actually a
few junior investigators in the bsrc
mostly working with ibis which i didn't
mention today but ibis is the infant
brain imaging study
um which is the imaging consortium of
infant's infant siblings and i have a
actually an r01 that actually has added
eeg to ibis and so we're
we work quite closely with them um
there's a whole subgroup that's been
developed on this question about the
ethics of early
screening and detection and so there's a
couple of things so first if we
if we think about just the early
screening detection forget the genetic
testing piece first it's just
what are the ethics around you know
identifying
early risk markers right and when i say
risk markers i mean
and there's a lot of controversy you've
been using the word risk so i'm using it
as a clinician meaning i'm thinking
about
you know identifying markers that herald
high likelihood of having a
neurodevelopmental disability later
right which comes with
you know challenges and a lot of costs
and other things for parents and
healthcare providers over the years
the question becomes if our predictors
aren't 100
accurate right that's one and two if we
do not
have actual treatments for all of these
conditions if you will especially if
it's polygenic risk or not
a known genetic cause then what are the
ethics behind that right
is it ethical to tell a parent you know
your child with a 50
chance of having autism when there's
nothing that we can actually
recommend um from a treatment standpoint
to
change that trajectory um and the answer
is we don't have a great answer that
there's a lot of dialogue about this
there's a lot being actually written in
the field about this
um but you know there are so the
argument pro screening
is that simply by more closely
monitoring and providing just the basic
behavioral interventions that are
available
we do believe that we improve outcomes
um compared to what we would do if we
never had
that early screening and surveillance
going on so those are the pros right
the cons though are that you know it's
adding stress to families right
we're telling parents well there's a
good chance that you're gonna have more
challenges but we can't tell you for
sure
you know and we know that parent stress
family stress those also are not
always protective right of of healthy
outcomes
so there are absolutely arguments prone
against and we get asked this question
we write grants in this area also like
you know
how do you mitigate the stress that
you're causing families
by you know you know with this kind of
work where you're just
following and screening so closely so it
definitely is a challenge i would say
that
you know then the added question around
genetic testing um you know now there's
prenatal
genetic testing available you know
through maternal
blood we can do it right and you can do
microarrays and other things
and we are not at a point where we have
gene therapies or therapies for all of
these causes
nor do we know a hundred percent what
the outcome will be in some of these
very rare variants
and so there's a lot of controversy over
the clinical value of
performing this kind of genetic testing
very early
so i think we're at the epicenter of
these of these um debates and i think
it's going to be a really interesting
you know next five years as we sort of
really sort out how
we um how we handle that i think you're
absolutely right some of these questions
are you know the technologies are
possible
right it's those but some of the ethical
questions about when to apply them
at what point in development or you know
who knows if you
wait you don't see something in a child
wait two weeks
maybe it'll show up but if you do
something before that you could you know
actually cause more harm than good one
thing i wanted to
uh ask you about from some of our
participants is do you think any of the
approaches might be effective perhaps as
protective treatments for
neurodegenerative disorders
affecting older adults
great question and i think that the
answer is yes i think it is possible you
know there's
sort of this again and my mentor chuck
nelson has been a part of these debates
about you know are there critical
periods in development are there
you know they're just sensitive periods
are there times that you know is there a
point in development where it's too late
right and i don't think any of us
believe that at all i think that thus
far there just have not been robust
enough trials in adults
especially with some of these more what
we would call disease modifying
therapies to know
if we ca if we would see a change or not
so i think it's worth exploring
um i do think though like word of
caution is that
you know kids are not just little adults
and so the kinds of measures we're using
the expectation of change you know even
our biomarkers need to be different
in our in our young populations compared
to what we might expect to see in adults
um but but i think that the adult spaces
is and i have actually a junior the abby
dickinson who did that
who wrote that paper that i showed you
on the um kind of machine learning with
eeg
in our highest defense she's actually
writing a k right now to look at
to look at sort of aging in autism and
to ask
exactly this question so the the
measures that seem most sensitive to
cognitive development for instance in
early infancy are those also sensitive
to aging processes might they predict
neurodegeneration or aging in autism so
um so that's an exciting year kathy
lord's going to be her primary mentor
and they're working on that right now so
um some more to come there but it's a
good question that's really cool and
well another question is
in us as people are looking at these
various biomarkers and looking at these
profiles across different disorders
whether it's autism or other
you know developmental delays or you
know any other um
sort of things are people seeing some
sort of commonalities across them that
would suggest
that you know there's actually fewer
independent diagnoses
than their you know we might have uh uh
carved the the population up into does
that make sense yes and actually i
and i saw that question in the chat and
what i will say is that and this is for
all of you data scientists
i want a figure like this with eg so my
point i would
love to see and it's not going to be
it's it's going to be complicated
because eg
there's it's fraught with variability
i'll just say that right but
you know we yes i think that you've like
you know convergence
at the level of genetics but there's
going to be convergence at the level of
sort of macro level circuit function
um and yes i mean there may be other
kids for i mean the simple examples
there may be other kids who have high
beta
that might be um amenable to similar
treatments that might be effective for
do 15q
for instance right but we need the issue
as again and i sound like i
actually didn't say it a lot in this
talk i say i say it all the time to my
lab and to others is
we just need big data right like we
can't
identify patterns and subgroups
with sample sizes of 50 kids with a
range of like we need and so you know
i've been working
one of my big goals at the bsrc was to
try to
harmonize eeg data across all of our
sites that are collecting eeg
um and we haven't really gotten there
yet and there's just
you know it's details us actually as to
why it hasn't happened um the ibis study
that i have that i didn't mention the
ibis grant that i have you know this is
joe pippen study
where they're prospectively um imaging
babies and it's a it's a substantial
sample size of 250 infants
so we got a grant to add eeg to that
study so at the end of the four-year
ibis study we will have eeg
prospectively collected and imaging on
250 infants
so that will be i think that'll give us
some nice um
that'll hopefully get us in the right
direction here but really we would
ideally want sample sizes that are even
larger
you know to really ask like are there
eeg patterns that help us select kids
for trials
well with that uh shefali thank you so
much for sharing
the work of your laboratory your your
thoughts and vision for
what you would like to see in this space
and i
completely agree um large-scale data
across multiple biomarkers across
multiple uh
constituents of our population are
really going to help get some insights
into
some of these developmental disorders as
you described so thank you so much i
appreciate it
um everyone thank you enjoy your weekend
and
we'll see you again next week thank you
so much awesome take care